Jessica starts off this hour in Dallas
Texas hi Jessica how are you I'm great
how are you better than I deserve what's
up okay well we just finished the Total
Money Makeover book and so we were
wanting to get started our situation is
that we are behind we just made our
budget we're behind on a few bills the
major ones with the car and the electric
and all that stuff but we're getting a
tax return about $7,000 and so you know
we made a column for our debt and you
have some medical credit cards and a car
kind of figure out how to use refund
what's the smartest way to do it my
husband wants to pay off the credit
cards first he would be wrong the first
thing you need to do is be current okay
bring everything current that's the
first thing and then we're going to list
your debts smallest to largest I want
you to set aside $1,000 as a beginner
starter emergency fund have you totaled
up what it'll take to get you completely
current no probably about when maybe
about 800 okay let's call it a thousand
for real numbers okay so let's say
$1,000 brings you 100% current on all
bills okay mm-hmm you're not behind with
anybody not a soul then we're going to
take the foot then that starts the baby
steps once you're current and baby step
one is to set aside $1,000 as your
beginner starter emergency fund a little
tiny rainy day fund won't cover my drain
but it will cover a little bit okay then
the baby step two is to pay off all of
your debts using the debt snowball and
that's paying minimum payments on
everything but the little one and attack
the debts and the smaller in order of
smallest to largest and your smallest
debts will be probably your medical
debts aren't they
yes okay and what would all those little
ankle-biters total would you think well
the problem is that the we haven't paid
any bit because my husband is in it
called commission so that's kind of why
he's falling behind they're keeping
really slow mines here and so I'll
credit or two credit cards are like the
worth the minimum mando they're like a
thousand each probably a little more
we're behind what are we on everything
but to enter that question I guess
they're smaller I'm showing not that we
got your current a while ago I thought
that was including debt as well
yeah all bills a thousand I'll bring you
current on everything will it no no I
was doing a regular bills like electric
until turning what will it take to bring
you a hundred percent current on all of
your debts god I'm scared I don't know
probably two grand maybe hilary alright
then let's use the same principle okay
let's say it's three thousand okay the
first thing you do is you get current on
all your bills all your cats where
you're a hundred percent current that's
your first step okay that's three
thousand and then we set a thousand
aside and baby step one that's four
thousand then we're going to list for
that smallest to largest what's the
little medical bills what would they
total up to be roughly just roughly just
as an example four thousand okay so that
would use up the rest of the money then
how much is write on your credit cards
the two credit cards runnings about
4,000 and 6,000 okay so no I would not
pay off the credit cards I'm going to
list your debts individually smallest to
largest and go as far down that list as
I can go after I've done those other two
things you follow me yes and then then
what you need to do is you need to
assess is his income see here's the
thing straight Commission's not a
problem if you're making a lot of money
straight Commission's only a problem
when it's code for I don't make any
money
he made about fifty nine thousand last
year okay then why would you be behind
on your car well he got a promotion into
the finance department but it wasn't all
it was cracked up to be and so those six
months we were barely getting paid
anything so he decided to go back to the
failed floor where he was making more
money so now we're just trying to play
catch-up so he's in the car business yes
okay all right good and so as we had a
couple of good months now God looking
yeah it's starting to pick up a little
bit okay so you think he's going to make
enough next month to pay the bills if we
bring this current that's my constant
prayer I know I nodded about your prayer
ask what you really thought I mean there
is only well as he made the bills for
the last two months if you'd been
current yes okay yes
and so he's trending in that direction
so it's reasonable to think that that
might occur yes we want to pray about it
yes we want to have hope okay I'm with
you on that part of it but we also need
to do reasonable forecasting because if
you need five thousand dollars a month
to live and he's made a thousand dollars
for the last four months then you know
praying about it now is one thing but
looking at where you really stand is
another okay pray at that point you're
praying for a miracle okay and that's
not yeah that's a different scenario so
um all right as long as you think once
your current he can maintain now that
he's back on the sales floor then I
would go with the plan I laid out for
you okay and I'll send you a copy I'll
send you a copy the book the Total Money
Makeover which outlines exactly why I
told you to do this and exactly how to
do it how those baby steps that we're
talking about work and why they work and
why so many people have done this
millions of people I've used this
process Jessica so this is something I
just made up when you called in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]